Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. It was around 7.45pm on Monday, November 16, 2009, when a 911 operator in Utah picked up a call from a woman named Pamela Mortensen. She explained that she and her husband had just survived a home invasion at a house belonging to Pamela's father-in-law, Kay Mortensen. Pamela said that perpetrators had tied her and her husband up in the living room while telling them Kay was
我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您在应用程序或我们网站上本剧集的节目说明。2009年11月16日星期一晚上7点45分左右，犹他州的一名911接线员接到了一个名叫帕梅拉·莫滕森（Pamela Mortensen）的女性打来的电话。她解释说，她和丈夫刚刚在帕梅拉的公公凯·莫滕森（Kay Mortensen）的家中经历了一场入室抢劫。帕梅拉说，作案者将她和丈夫绑在客厅里，并告诉他们凯被
restrained on the second floor. Pamela seemed unable to recall how many offenders were involved, hesitating as she said, um, there could have been. been three. She explained they had been ordered not to look at the intruders, so she couldn't describe their features. Pamela also claimed it had been too dark for her to see what kind of car they were driving. When asked if the intruders had been white, black or Hispanic, Pamela replied in a slightly terse tone, ma'am, I don't know. The operator found the call strange. For someone who had just lived through such a traumatic experience, Pamela's voice was calm and steady. Her answers were also vague and unhelpful. Pamela said that she thought her father-in-law might
关在二楼。帕梅拉似乎无法回忆起有多少名罪犯参与，她犹豫着说，嗯，可能有……有三个人。她解释说，他们被命令不要看入侵者，所以她无法描述他们的特征。帕梅拉还声称当时太黑了，她看不清他们开的是什么车。当被问及入侵者是白人、黑人还是西班牙裔时，帕梅拉用一种略显生硬的语气回答说，女士，我不知道。接线员觉得这通电话很奇怪。对于一个刚刚经历过如此创伤性事件的人来说，帕梅拉的声音平静而稳定。她的回答也很模糊，毫无帮助。帕梅拉说她认为她的公公可能
be dead, but she wasn't sure. The operator asked to speak to Pamela's husband, Roger Mortensen, instead. When Roger took the phone, he said there had been two intruders and both were white. They had stolen his driver's license from his wallet and threatened to harm Roger and his family if he called the police. Roger explained that after the intruders left and he'd escaped his restraints, he went upstairs to find his father. Kay Mortensen was on the bathroom floor, cold to the touch. Roger remarked, matter-of-factly, He's leaned over facing forward in the bathtub with his throat sliced with a butcher knife all the way up. The operator asked if Roger knew why anyone would want to harm Kay.
已经死了，但她不确定。接线员要求与帕梅拉的丈夫罗杰·莫滕森（Roger Mortensen）通话。当罗杰接起电话时，他说有两名入侵者，而且都是白人。他们从他的钱包里偷走了他的驾照，并威胁说如果他报警就伤害罗杰和他的家人。罗杰解释说，在入侵者离开且他挣脱束缚后，他上楼去找他的父亲。凯·莫滕森躺在浴室的地板上，身体已经冰凉。罗杰客观地评论道：“他俯身面朝前趴在浴缸里，喉咙被屠夫刀彻底割开了。”接线员问罗杰是否知道为什么有人会想伤害凯。
Roger answered, Yeah, he's rich. Deputies from the county sheriff's department were dispatched to Kay Mortensen's address near Payson, Utah. The large house sat on a hill at the end of a winding driveway and was well. one of two houses owned by 70-year-old Kay. He and his wife Dala spent most of their time at their primary residence in St. George, about 250 miles south near the Arizona border. But they usually checked in on the Payson property about twice a month. Lately, they hadn't been there much at all. Both Kay and Dala were devoted members of the Church of Jesus Christ of Latter-day Saints. Three weeks
罗杰回答说：“是的，他很有钱。”县治安官办公室的副警长被派往凯·莫滕森位于犹他州佩森（Payson）附近的住址。这座大房子坐落在一条蜿蜒车道尽头的小山上，是70岁的凯拥有的两处房产之一。他和妻子达拉（Dala）大部分时间都住在他们位于圣乔治（St. George）的主要住所，那里在亚利桑那州边境附近，向南约250英里。但他们通常每月会去佩森的房产查看两次。最近，他们几乎没怎么去过那里。凯和达拉都是耶稣基督后期圣徒教会的忠实成员。三周
earlier, they'd completed an 18-month mission together at Fort Cove, Utah. The older couple had only been married for about three years and had bonded over their dedication to their church. Kay's 48-year-old son, Roger, the eldest of his three adult children, lived near the Payson residence and had been checking on it often while they were away. Shortly after Kay and Dala finished their mission, Kay went to stay at the house while Dala went to look after her granddaughters in Salt Lake City, which was about an hour away. Dala was due to rejoin her husband later that night, and then she and Kay had been planning to return to their St. George residence the next day.
前，他们刚在犹他州科夫堡（Fort Cove）共同完成了为期18个月的传教任务。这对年长的夫妇结婚才大约三年，因对教会的奉献而结缘。凯48岁的儿子罗杰是他三个成年子女中的长子，住在佩森住所附近，在他们离开期间经常去查看。在凯和达拉完成传教任务后不久，凯去那栋房子住，而达拉去盐湖城照顾她的孙女们，那里距离大约一小时车程。达拉原定于当晚晚些时候与丈夫团聚，然后她和凯计划第二天返回他们在圣乔治的住所。
Kay's son Roger and his 34-year-old wife Pamela told investigators that was why they'd decided to go over that evening. They thought it might be nice to spend some time with Kay. and Dala before they left. Pamela had phoned Dala's cell phone and asked if they'd like to play board games later that evening. Dala agreed. Pamela had received a Pekam Pye at work earlier that day, and knowing it was Kay's favourite, she and Roger decided to bring it with them. Roger and Pamela provided a more detailed version of the story they'd shared with 9-1-1. Prior to going to Kay's house, they had tried calling his landline and his cell phone.
凯的儿子罗杰和他34岁的妻子帕梅拉告诉调查人员，这就是他们决定那天晚上过去的原因。他们认为在他们离开之前和凯及达拉待一会儿可能会很好。帕梅拉给达拉的手机打了电话，问他们那天晚上晚些时候是否想玩棋盘游戏。达拉同意了。帕梅拉那天早些时候在工作中收到了一块山核桃派，知道这是凯的最爱，她和罗杰决定把它带上。罗杰和帕梅拉提供了比他们告诉911时更详细的故事版本。在去凯家之前，他们曾尝试拨打他的座机和手机。
Both calls went unanswered. This wasn't unusual, as sometimes Kay would doze off and not hear his phones. Roger and Pamela drove over with the Peacampy just as dusk was falling. When they arrived at Kay's house, they noticed an unfamiliar car parked in the driveway. Roger identified it as a compact hatchback-style vehicle that was a. dark in colour, possibly blue. Lights were on inside the house. Figuring that perhaps Kay had company over and that's why he hadn't answered the phone, Roger and Pamela knocked on the door. It was answered by an unfamiliar young white male who the couple said they thought was a handyman.
两通电话都无人接听。这并不罕见，因为凯有时会打瞌睡而听不到电话。罗杰和帕梅拉带着山核桃派在黄昏时分开车过去。当他们到达凯家时，他们注意到车道上停着一辆陌生的车。罗杰将其辨认为一辆紧凑型掀背式汽车，颜色较深，可能是蓝色的。房子里亮着灯。罗杰和帕梅拉以为凯可能有客人，所以没接电话，于是敲了敲门。门被一个陌生的年轻白人男子打开，这对夫妇说他们以为那是修理工。
Kay had been having issues with his internet connection lately and was also planning on replacing some carpet. Pamela assumed the man was there to help with one of those tasks. Pamela asked if Kay was home and the man said yes, he was upstairs. Pamela explained that they were there to drop off a pie and the man replied, go ahead. Pamela and Roger entered the home and Pamela made her way up a set of interior steps that led inside. Then she heard the man ask her to come back down as the front door clicked shut behind her. At the same time, a second man appeared on the staircase that led to the first floor and began walking towards them. In his hands were a number of zip ties and a black semi-automatic handgun. You're in the wrong place at the wrong time,
凯最近互联网连接一直有问题，也打算更换一些地毯。帕梅拉以为那个人是来帮忙处理其中一项任务的。帕梅拉问凯是否在家，那个人说是的，他在楼上。帕梅拉解释说他们是来送派的，那个人回答说：“进去吧。”帕梅拉和罗杰进入屋内，帕梅拉走上一组通往内部的室内楼梯。然后她听到那个人让她下来，前门在她身后咔哒一声关上了。与此同时，第二名男子出现在通往一楼的楼梯上，开始向他们走来。他手里拿着一些扎带和一把黑色半自动手枪。“你们在错误的时间出现在了错误的地点，”
he told the couple. He ordered them to bind each other's wrists with the zip ties before marching them into Kay's living room. According to Roger and Pamela, they were clean-cut white men aged in their early to mid-20s and dressed in Levi jeans and t-shirts. Both had short hair that appeared to have been dyed black and moustaches or goatees. The couple said they looked the same. Roger believed they were the same height and size as him, making them around 5'9 and between 150 to 165 pounds. Roger tried to bargain with the men, begging, just let us leave, let us take our pecan pie and leave. But the men refused, making the couple kneel on the living room floor in front of the television instead. Then they bound their ankles with the zip tires as well.
他告诉这对夫妇。他命令他们用扎带绑住彼此的手腕，然后将他们赶进凯的客厅。据罗杰和帕梅拉说，他们是长相干净的白人男子，年龄在20岁出头到20岁中期，穿着李维斯牛仔裤和T恤。两人都留着短发，看起来染成了黑色，并留着胡子或山羊胡。这对夫妇说他们看起来一模一样。罗杰认为他们和他的身高体型相同，大约5英尺9英寸（约1.75米），体重在150到165磅（约68到75公斤）之间。罗杰试图与这些人讨价还价，恳求道：“让我们走吧，让我们带上我们的山核桃派离开。”但这些人拒绝了，而是让他们跪在客厅电视机前的地板上。然后他们也用扎带绑住了他们的脚踝。
When Pamela asked where Kay was, they told her he was restrained upstairs. The couple said the intruders were almost polite. Roger had a back injury and they checked that he was comfortable as they restrained him. But they were threatening as well. They rummaged through the couple's pockets, confiscating their cell phones and IDs. At one point, one of the men said that because Roger and Pamela had seen their faces, they would have to kill them. Pamela felt panicked until she noticed a picture of Jesus Christ that Kay had hanging on the wall. Being a woman of faith, the picture gave her comfort.
当帕梅拉问凯在哪里时，他们告诉她他被关在楼上。这对夫妇说入侵者甚至很有礼貌。罗杰背部有伤，他们在捆绑他时还确认他是否感到舒适。但他们也进行了威胁。他们翻遍了这对夫妇的口袋，没收了他们的手机和身份证。有一次，其中一名男子说，因为罗杰和帕梅拉看到了他们的脸，他们必须杀了他们。帕梅拉感到恐慌，直到她注意到凯挂在墙上的一张耶稣基督的画像。作为一个有信仰的女性，这张画像给了她安慰。
She began praying silently to God, repeating the words, If you're there, save me. Soon, the two men headed outside, leaving the couple alone in the living room. There was a large window in the room that looked out over the east side of the property. Pamela gazed out the window and saw a figure standing outside in the dimming light, holding what looked like a broom. The figure noticed Pam looking and gestured for her to look away. She did so and told Roger he should also keep his head down.
她开始默默地向上帝祈祷，重复着：“如果你在那里，救救我。”很快，这两个人走到外面，把这对夫妇独自留在客厅里。房间里有一扇大窗户，可以俯瞰房产的东侧。帕梅拉向窗外望去，看到一个身影站在昏暗的光线下，手里拿着看起来像扫帚的东西。那个身影注意到帕梅拉在看，便示意她别看。她照做了，并告诉罗杰他也应该低下头。
The couple said they were left alone in the room for between 30 and 45 minutes. At one point, Roger started to pray aloud. Like his father, he was a member of the LDS Church. Eventually, the two men returned. Pamela nudged to Roger, indicating he should be quiet due to the men's presence. Roger stopped, but the men told him, to continue. Then they folded their arms across their chests and bowed their heads, which was the traditional praying stance in the LDS faith, while listening in silence. When Roger finished his prayer,
这对夫妇说他们被单独留在房间里大约30到45分钟。有一次，罗杰开始大声祈祷。像他父亲一样，他是后期圣徒教会的成员。最终，那两个人回来了。帕梅拉推了推罗杰，示意他因为这些人的存在应该保持安静。罗杰停了下来，但这些人告诉他：“继续。”然后他们双臂交叉在胸前，低下了头，这是后期圣徒信仰中传统的祈祷姿势，同时静静地听着。当罗杰结束祈祷时，
one of the men pulled up a barstool and sat down in front of the couple. He began peppering them with questions, asking if they knew of any visitors Kay might be expecting. They told him Kay's wife Dala would be coming home soon. The man looked unfazed and unsurprised to hear this. Then he asked if Roger and Pamela had any children and whether anyone was waiting for them to return home. These questions made Roger and Pamela nervous. It sounded like their lives were hanging in the balance depending on how they answered.
其中一名男子拉过一张吧台凳，坐在这对夫妇面前。他开始连珠炮似地问他们问题，问他们是否知道凯可能在等什么访客。他们告诉他凯的妻子达拉很快就会回家。那个人听到这个消息后看起来很镇定，并不感到惊讶。然后他问罗杰和帕梅拉是否有孩子，以及是否有人在等他们回家。这些问题让罗杰和帕梅拉感到紧张。听起来他们的生命取决于他们如何回答。
But something had shifted in the man's demeanour after hearing Roger pray. He said they had decided to let the couple go. He told them they should tell the police that three black men were responsible for the crime and kept Roger's driver's licence so he had his home address. If Roger told the police the truth, the man warned, quote, We will hurt your family. Roger and Pamela told the sheriff's deputies about this script they had been told to follow and said that was why their 911 call had been odd.
但在听到罗杰祈祷后，那个人的态度发生了一些转变。他说他们决定放这对夫妇走。他告诉他们，他们应该告诉警察是三名黑人男子犯下了这起罪行，并留下了罗杰的驾照，这样他就有了他的家庭住址。那个人警告说，如果罗杰告诉警察真相，“我们会伤害你的家人。”罗杰和帕梅拉告诉治安官的副警长他们被告知要遵循这个剧本，并说这就是为什么他们的911电话听起来很奇怪。
They weren't sure whether to tell the truth or their attacker's story. After the two men fled the property in the blue hatchback, Roger and Pamela had waited about 45 minutes before removing their bindings. They said they were scared that the men might come back. Pamela said she had first wriggled out of the zip tires on her wrist, then reached into Roger's pocket for his keys because he kept a pocket knife on his key chain. She then used the knife to cut off Roger's ties and the ones around their ankles. Once they were freed, Pamela picked up a nearby phone to call 911 while Roger checked on his father.
他们不确定是该说实话还是该说袭击者的故事。在那两名男子开着蓝色掀背车逃离房产后，罗杰和帕梅拉等了大约45分钟才解开束缚。他们说他们害怕这些人可能会回来。帕梅拉说她先是从手腕上的扎带中挣脱出来，然后伸手去拿罗杰口袋里的钥匙，因为他的钥匙链上有一把折叠刀。然后她用刀割断了罗杰的束缚以及他们脚踝上的束缚。一旦他们获救，帕梅拉拿起附近的电话拨打911，而罗杰去查看他的父亲。
First, he looked out a window by the front door to make sure the intruder's car was gone. Then he locked the door and jammed a stick in another sliding glass. door to prevent anyone from entering. After this, he finally headed upstairs. Pamela was speaking to the 911 operator when Roger found his father's body in a small bathroom. Kay was kneeling over the bathtub which had a sliding glass door. As well as a deep slash to Kay's throat, he had been stabbed in the back of their neck. The murder weapon, a sharp kitchen knife with a long blood-stained blade,
首先，他看了看前门旁边的窗户，确保入侵者的车已经走了。然后他锁上门，并在另一扇滑动玻璃门上塞了一根棍子，以防止任何人进入。此后，他终于上楼了。帕梅拉正在与911接线员通话时，罗杰在小浴室里发现了父亲的尸体。凯跪在有一个滑动玻璃门的浴缸上。除了喉咙上有深深的割伤外，他的后颈也被刺伤了。凶器，一把带有长长血迹刀片的锋利厨房刀，
was lying in the bathtub. The knife had been taken from Kay's own kitchen. Roger went back downstairs to tell Pamela that Kay was dead, and she passed this on to 911 before handing the phone to Roger. Responding officers noted that there was surprisingly little damage for a home invasion. Someone had gone to a great effort to keep the crime scene tidy, even killing Kay over the bathtub to avoid spilling blood on the floor. Forensic investigators couldn't recover any useful DNA or fingerprints from the house. They believed this indicated the perpetrators either had lots of time to clean up or there hadn't been much of a struggle at all.
躺在浴缸里。这把刀是从凯自己的厨房里拿走的。罗杰回到楼下告诉帕梅拉凯已经死了，她在把电话交给罗杰之前将此传达给了911。响应的警官注意到，对于一场入室抢劫来说，现场的破坏程度出奇地小。有人费了很大力气保持犯罪现场整洁，甚至在浴缸上方杀害凯以避免血液溅到地板上。法医调查人员无法从房子里提取到任何有用的DNA或指纹。他们认为这表明作案者要么有大量时间清理，要么根本没有发生过激烈的挣扎。
Roger had told 9-1-1 that the intruders must have targeted his father because he was rich. This was backed up by something one of the men had said. supposedly told the couple, stating that they were robbing Kay to support their families. But Kay's valuables had been left behind, mostly. Kay Mortensen loved guns and spent a lot of money adding to his firearm collection. In total, he owned about 100, some of which were extremely valuable. Kay's firearms were scattered throughout the house, but he kept about 20 in an outdoor underground concrete bunker that he'd built himself.
罗杰曾告诉911，入侵者一定是冲着他父亲来的，因为他很有钱。这一点得到了其中一名男子所说的话的支持，据称他告诉这对夫妇，他们抢劫凯是为了养家糊口。但凯的贵重物品大多被留下了。凯·莫滕森热爱枪支，花了很多钱扩充他的枪支收藏。总共他拥有大约100支，其中一些极其珍贵。凯的枪支散落在房子各处，但他把大约20支放在了他自己建造的一个户外地下混凝土掩体里。
Kay was a survivalist who believed in self-protection and had built the bunker in case of an emergency. It was stocked with everything he and his wife Dala could have a need to survive, food, water, weapons, first aid supplies, and even reading materials. Only his closest friends and family knew about the bunker. Investigators soon discovered that the shelves in the bunker were empty. All of the firearms he had stored down there were missing. It didn't take long for investigators to grow suspicious.
凯是一个相信自我保护的生存主义者，并建造了这个掩体以备不时之需。里面储备了他和妻子达拉生存所需的一切：食物、水、武器、急救用品，甚至还有阅读材料。只有他最亲密的朋友和家人知道这个掩体。调查人员很快发现掩体里的架子是空的。他存放在那里的所有枪支都不见了。调查人员没过多久就产生了怀疑。
Something about Roger and Pamela's story wasn't adding up for them. First of all, the crime scene didn't add up. Roger and Pamela had said the men were strangers, but there was no sign of forced entry. Draws and safes throughout the house were left untouched. It didn't look like the place had been ransacked, as would be expected, if random burglars were responsible. Nor did it look like any of the victims had put up a struggle. It also seemed as though the man had somehow known about Kay's secret bunker. The only firearms stolen were the ones kept in there,
罗杰和帕梅拉的故事对他们来说有些对不上号。首先，犯罪现场对不上。罗杰和帕梅拉说这些人是陌生人，但没有强行闯入的迹象。房子里的抽屉和保险箱都没有被动过。看起来不像被洗劫过，如果真的是随机窃贼所为，本应如此。看起来受害者也没有进行过任何挣扎。似乎那个人还以某种方式知道了凯的秘密掩体。被盗的唯一枪支是存放在那里的那些，
even though Kay's most valuable, exclusive and antique guns were in his bed. bedroom, locked away in two separate safes. The safes also held Kay's gold and silver coin collections. As a survivalist who was mistrustful of the government, Kay had invested in these coins to ensure his wealth would remain during periods of potential disaster or economic downturn. When a locksmith managed to open the safes up for law enforcement, they saw that none of the coins or Kay's valuable guns had been stolen. Investigators thought the entire situation looked more like someone staging a burglary without wanting to actually lose any items of value.
尽管凯最珍贵、最独特和古董级的枪支都在他的卧室里，锁在两个独立的保险箱中。保险箱里还存放着凯的金币和银币收藏。作为一个不信任政府的生存主义者，凯投资了这些硬币，以确保他的财富在潜在灾难或经济衰退期间能够保值。当锁匠设法为执法部门打开保险箱时，他们发现没有任何硬币或凯的贵重枪支被盗。调查人员认为整个情况看起来更像是有人在策划入室盗窃，却不想真正损失任何有价值的物品。
Other aspects of the scene also seemed strange. Pamela had said she'd seen one of the men standing outside the living room window holding a broom, but a fresh area of snow showed no signs of footprints or someone having swept in the vicinity. There was evidence of a snowy patch having been swept on the north side of the house. However, Pamela wouldn't have been able to see this area if she'd been held hostage in the living room as she claimed. Although Pamela had said she'd cut off the majority of the couple's zip tires, the discarded tyres were intact and hadn't been cut.
现场的其他方面也显得很奇怪。帕梅拉说她看到其中一名男子站在客厅窗外拿着一把扫帚，但新鲜的积雪区域没有显示出任何脚印或有人在附近清扫的迹象。有证据表明房子北侧的一块积雪区域被清扫过。然而，如果帕梅拉像她声称的那样被扣为人质关在客厅里，她是不可能看到这个区域的。尽管帕梅拉说她割断了这对夫妇大部分的扎带，但丢弃的扎带是完整的，并没有被割断。
Pamela claimed to have stretched the ones on her wrists to remove them. but when investigators experimented with the tires, they found the plastic was too hard to stretch. Nor were there any marks on the couple's wrists, which would have been left by tight zip tires. Investigators suspected Pamela and Roger had secured the restraints loosely to make it look as though they were taken hostage without actually being tied up. The fact that Kay Mortensen had been murdered with a knife seemed vicious and personal. not what you'd expect to see if he'd been killed by two strangers who were carrying a handgun. As well as being a survivalist who was armed and on high alert to defend himself,
帕梅拉声称她拉伸了手腕上的扎带以将其取下，但当调查人员对扎带进行实验时，他们发现塑料太硬，无法拉伸。这对夫妇的手腕上也没有任何痕迹，而紧绷的扎带本应留下痕迹。调查人员怀疑帕梅拉和罗杰松松地系上了束缚，以使看起来像是被劫持为人质，而实际上并没有被绑住。凯·莫滕森被刀杀害的事实看起来既残忍又具有个人恩怨，这与如果他被两名携带手枪的陌生人杀害时所预期的不同。除了是一个武装且高度警惕以保护自己的生存主义者外，
Kay had a black belt in karate. He should have been able to fight back against intruders who turned up at his home. It seemed far more likely that he'd been targeted by people he knew and trusted when his guard was down. Finally, investigators were struck by what they perceived as Roger and Pamela's strange demeanors. Both appeared calm and not in the least bit grief-stricken, despite the grisly scene at Kay's home or their own supposed ordeal. The details of their stories seemed to change, and there were elements that were just plain odd, like Roger saying he'd asked the intruders if they could take their pecan pie and leave. Why would he be thinking about the Pecan Pie in such a stressful situation?
凯还拥有空手道黑带。他本应有能力反抗出现在他家中的入侵者。他更有可能是被他认识并信任的人在放松警惕时盯上的。最后，调查人员对他们所认为的罗杰和帕梅拉奇怪的态度感到震惊。尽管凯的家中出现了可怕的场景，或者他们自己所谓的磨难，但两人看起来都很平静，一点也不悲伤。他们故事的细节似乎在变，而且有些元素简直太奇怪了，比如罗杰说他问入侵者是否可以带上他们的山核桃派离开。为什么他在如此紧张的情况下会想到山核桃派？
The sheriff's deputies realised they needed to separate Roger and Pamela Mortensen, then interview them individually. They placed the couple in two different deputies' cars in order to drive them down to the station. One deputy noticed Roger making eye contact with Pamela through their car windows. He was grinning at his wife and gave her a thumbs up. When he realised the deputy was watching him, his smile immediately vanished and he put his hands in his lap. Pamela still seemed calm and was chatty with the deputies who escorted her to the station. She talked about her work and several television programs she was missing due to the evening's events. During her interrogation, detectives noted a complete absence of emotion when she discussed her deceased father-in-law.
治安官的副警长意识到他们需要将罗杰和帕梅拉·莫滕森分开，然后分别审问他们。他们将这对夫妇分别放在两辆不同的副警长车里，以便将他们带到警察局。一名副警长注意到罗杰通过车窗与帕梅拉进行眼神交流。他对着妻子咧嘴一笑，并向她竖起了大拇指。当他意识到副警长在看着他时，他的笑容立刻消失了，并把手放在膝盖上。帕梅拉看起来仍然很平静，并与护送她去警察局的副警长们聊天。她谈到了她的工作以及因为当晚的事件而错过的几个电视节目。在审讯期间，侦探们注意到她在讨论她已故的公公时完全没有情绪。
They showed Pamela a photo lineup of possible suspects, but she didn't recognize any. One detective cut to the chase, stating, This story is a bunch of crap that you and Roger have come up with, okay? Is your husband capable of killing somebody? Pamela stammered slightly in her reply, saying, I wouldn't hope. I mean, I wouldn't think he is. I wouldn't think that he's capable of killing.
他们向帕梅拉展示了一份可能的嫌疑人照片阵容，但她一个也没认出来。一名侦探直截了当地说：“这个故事是你和罗杰编造的一堆废话，好吗？你丈夫有能力杀人吗？”帕梅拉在回答时稍微结巴了一下，说：“我不希望……我的意思是，我不认为他是。我不认为他有能力杀害……”
killing his father. I know we are in a lot of debt, but we, I personally, would not have my father-in-law killed for his money. While Roger was being driven to the sheriff's department, he seemed relaxed and eager to chat. He asked lots of questions about the equipment in the deputy's car and was keen to know how it all worked. While waiting to be taken into an interview room, he continued to talk, telling deputies about his job and other random topics. A couple of times he referred to his father's death, but he didn't seem upset and never cried. At one point he described his father as, quote, a cantankerous old fart. Sometimes he stood up to stretch, explaining that he had an uncomfortable back injury.
“杀害他的父亲。我知道我们欠了很多债，但我，我个人，不会为了钱而让我的公公被杀。”当罗杰被带往治安官办公室时，他看起来很放松，急于聊天。他问了很多关于副警长车内设备的问题，并渴望知道它是如何工作的。在等待被带入审讯室时，他继续说话，告诉副警长关于他的工作和其他随机话题。有几次他提到了他父亲的死，但他看起来并不难过，也从未哭过。有一次他形容他的父亲是“一个脾气暴躁的老混蛋”。有时他站起来伸展身体，解释说他背部有不舒服的伤。
Roger was quick to suggest possible suspects, including a former student of his father's named Mike who owed Kay money. Kay had taken some of Mike's guns as collateral and was storing them in the bunker. Now they were all gone. Detectives quickly tracked Mike down and established that he had an airtight alibi for the evening. Mike also explained that Kay had bought the guns from him because he needed money. Some of the details in Roger's story changed during his interview. He said the suspects had been wearing fuzzy blue women's gloves. Then he later said they hadn't been wearing gloves at all.
罗杰很快提出了可能的嫌疑人，包括他父亲的一名前学生，名叫迈克，他欠凯钱。凯拿走了迈克的一些枪作为抵押，并把它们存放在掩体里。现在它们都不见了。侦探们很快找到了迈克，并确定他当晚有不在场证明。迈克还解释说，凯买下这些枪是因为他需要钱。罗杰故事中的一些细节在审讯期间发生了变化。他说嫌疑人戴着模糊的蓝色女式手套。然后他后来又说他们根本没戴手套。
But for the most part, his version of events stayed the same. Roger again told the story of how the men had changed their minds about killing them after hearing him pray. This struck investigators as particularly implausible. It seemed absurd that the men had changed. the men would viciously kill Kay Mortensen in cold blood, then allow two witnesses to live. They told Roger Mortensen as such and said they didn't believe what he and Pamela were saying. Roger replied,
但在大多数情况下，他的事件版本保持不变。罗杰再次讲述了这些人如何在听到他祈祷后改变了杀害他们的主意。这让调查人员觉得特别不可信。这些人会冷血地残忍杀害凯·莫滕森，然后让两名证人活着，这看起来很荒谬。他们告诉罗杰·莫滕森事实如此，并说他们不相信他和帕梅拉所说的话。罗杰回答说，
I'm sorry you don't believe me, but... Then he trailed off. He shrugged and rested his head in one hand before looking at one of the detectives and asking, Does it sound too rehearsed or... The detective told him it did. Okay, was all Roger said in reply. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors.
“很抱歉你们不相信我，但是……”然后他没再说下去。他耸了耸肩，一只手托着头，看着其中一名侦探问道：“听起来太像排练过的了吗，或者……”侦探告诉他确实如此。“好吧，”罗杰回答说。案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本剧集的赞助商来支持我们。
Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. Looking into Kay Mortensen's life, investigators quickly realized he'd been a complex individual. Kay had enjoyed a long career as a professor at Brigham Young University, an LDS tertiary institution. He taught the subjects of engineering technology, manufacturing technology and manufacturing design, and was popular with his students. They liked the way he told stories to capture their interest instead of just lecturing at them.
感谢您收听本剧集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供高质量的内容。调查凯·莫滕森的生活，调查人员很快意识到他是一个复杂的人。凯在杨百翰大学（Brigham Young University，一所后期圣徒高等教育机构）担任教授，职业生涯很长。他教授工程技术、制造技术和制造设计等学科，深受学生欢迎。他们喜欢他用讲故事的方式来吸引他们的兴趣，而不是仅仅对他们说教。
In addition to his successful career, Kay had made a number of financial investments over the years that had made him a multi-millionaire. He was known to be generous with his wealth, sharing it with those he loved. A few people owed him money from substantial loans he'd given them, but those who knew Kay said he hadn't been worried or pressured anyone to repay him. At the same time, Kay could rub some people the wrong way. He was described as opinionated, dogmatic, stubborn and quick-tempered. Sometimes he got into arguments about politics or religion, and there was a number of failed relationships in his past. Kay had been married and divorced twice before meeting Dala.
除了成功的职业生涯外，凯多年来还进行了许多金融投资，使他成为千万富翁。他以慷慨对待财富而闻名，与他所爱的人分享。有些人因为他给他们的大额贷款而欠他钱，但那些了解凯的人说他并不担心，也没有向任何人施压要求还款。与此同时，凯可能会让一些人感到不快。他被描述为固执己见、教条主义、顽固且脾气暴躁。有时他会因为政治或宗教问题而争吵，他的过去也有过几次失败的关系。在遇到达拉之前，凯结过两次婚并离过两次婚。
He'd had a falling out with his sister regarding guardianship for their mother and disabled brother, and Kay had disowned one of his sons who held a long-standing graph. due to Kay not paying his child support or funding his college education. Detectives also learnt about a disagreement Kay had with a former business partner and a particularly troubling dispute with a neighbour. Three and a half years earlier in May 2006, Kay's neighbour Cindy let her pet Great Dane out of its kennel just as Kay was driving past the property. According to Cindy, the dog had started barking at a dog.
他曾因母亲和残疾兄弟的监护权问题与妹妹闹翻，凯还与他的一名儿子断绝了关系，因为凯没有支付子女抚养费或资助他的大学教育，导致儿子怀恨在心。侦探们还了解到了凯与一名前商业伙伴的分歧，以及与邻居之间特别令人不安的纠纷。三年半前的2006年5月，凯的邻居辛迪（Cindy）在凯开车经过房产时，把她的宠物大丹犬放出了狗舍。据辛迪说，狗开始对着凯吠叫。
K. In response, Kay had stopped his car and shot the dog dead. K claimed that the Great Dane had attacked him and he only shot it in self-defense. He was subsequently charged with animal cruelty and discharging a firearm from a vehicle. He pleaded not guilty to both charges and eventually beat the case. Despite these disputes throughout Kay's past, investigators quickly concluded that they had nothing to do with his murder. In addition to questioning his son Roger and daughter-in-law Pamela, detectives made interviewing Kay's wife Dala a top priority. On the evening of Monday, November 16, Dala Mortensen was driving home to the Payson
作为回应，凯停下车，开枪打死了那只狗。凯声称大丹犬袭击了他，他只是出于自卫才开枪。他随后被控虐待动物和从车内开枪。他对两项指控均表示不认罪，并最终赢得了官司。尽管凯的过去有这些纠纷，但调查人员很快得出结论，它们与他的谋杀案无关。除了审问他的儿子罗杰和儿媳帕梅拉外，侦探们将采访凯的妻子达拉列为首要任务。11月16日星期一晚上，达拉·莫滕森正开车回家前往佩森
Canyon property when she received a call from a neighbor. He'd noticed a commotion at the Mortensen residence, with the sheriff's deputies descending on the property. Dala's first thought was that her husband Kay must have shot a would-be burglar. He had always told her that if anyone tried to break into his property, he would kill them. Dala knew just how prepared he was for any kind of attack. Scared and panicked, she called a friend and asked them to meet her at the property. When Dala and her friend arrived at Pacing Canyon, they found that law enforcement had blocked off the street.
峡谷的房产，这时她接到了邻居的电话。他注意到莫滕森住所发生了骚乱，治安官的副警长们正在涌向该房产。达拉的第一反应是她的丈夫凯一定开枪打死了一个入室窃贼。他总是告诉她，如果有人试图闯入他的房产，他就会杀了他们。达拉知道他为任何形式的袭击做了多么充分的准备。害怕和恐慌中，她给一个朋友打电话，让他们在房产处与她会合。当达拉和她的朋友到达佩森峡谷时，他们发现执法部门已经封锁了街道。
Dala made her way to the nearest officer and explained the situation. She was taken to a command post that had been set up at the bottom of the hill that led to her home. Dala was informed that her husband hadn't killed an intruder as she'd expected. Instead, he was the victim of an attack. Dala looked grief-stricken. Detectives noted that her open distress was markedly different to how Kay's son Roger had appeared. According to those who knew Kay and Dala, their love had been deep, and Dala had a calming effect on her husband. Prior to getting married, she had agreed to sign a prenuptial agreement so Kay could protect his financial assets.
达拉走向最近的警官并解释了情况。她被带到了一个设在通往她家的小山底部的指挥所。达拉被告知她的丈夫并没有像她预期的那样杀掉入侵者。相反，他是袭击的受害者。达拉看起来悲痛欲绝。侦探们注意到她公开的痛苦与凯的儿子罗杰的表现截然不同。据那些了解凯和达拉的人说，他们的爱很深，达拉对她的丈夫有镇静作用。在结婚之前，她同意签署一份婚前协议，以便凯可以保护他的金融资产。
Dala told detectives that Kay had always been paranoid when it came to his personal safety. He carried a gun with him at all times and would insist they enter their homes via the garage instead of the front. door. The fact that he could have been caught off guard by intruders struck her as very unlikely. After listening to audio of Roger and Pamela Mortensen's police interviews, Dala told the detectives that she was concerned they might be involved. Investigators spoke to other members of the Mortensen family. Some mentioned that during Roger's childhood, he might have experienced physical and emotional abuse at Kay's hands. It turned out that Roger also had a criminal record.
达拉告诉侦探，凯在个人安全方面一直很偏执。他随身携带枪支，并坚持让他们通过车库而不是前门进入他们的家。他可能被入侵者打个措手不及的事实让她觉得非常不可能。在听了罗杰和帕梅拉·莫滕森的警察审讯录音后，达拉告诉侦探她担心他们可能参与其中。调查人员与莫滕森家族的其他成员进行了交谈。一些人提到，在罗杰的童年时期，他可能在凯的手下遭受过身体和情感虐待。事实证明，罗杰也有犯罪记录。
During his adult years, he had struggled with substance abuse, becoming addicted to cannabis and cocaine. It also sounded like he had a tamper. Thirteen years earlier, in 1996, a driver was taking some Boy Scouts on an excursion through American Fork Canyon when Roger Mortensen passed by them in an altar. rain vehicle. For some reason he became very agitated, stopped his ATV and pulled out a handgun. He began waving it at the other driver, who quickly continued on to escape him. They reported the incident to authorities who tracked Roger down and found both the gun
在他成年后的岁月里，他一直在与药物滥用作斗争，对大麻和可卡因上瘾。听起来他脾气也很暴躁。13年前的1996年，一名司机正带着一些童子军在美利坚福克峡谷（American Fork Canyon）进行短途旅行，当时罗杰·莫滕森开着一辆全地形车从他们身边经过。出于某种原因，他变得非常激动，停下他的全地形车并掏出一把手枪。他开始向另一名司机挥舞，后者迅速继续前行以逃离他。他们向当局报告了这一事件，当局追踪到了罗杰并发现了枪支
and a cannabis pipe in his possession. He also had a radar unit that had been stolen from Utah Highway Patrol, valued at $4,000. Roger was charged with aggravated assault, drug possession and receiving stolen property. He pleaded no contest and his charges were reduced, resulting in him receiving probation. The following year, Roger helped a friend steal dozens of tools from a hardware store. Roger had also been married three times prior to meeting Pamela. In 1999, Roger and his then wife sought protective orders against each other. According to Roger's wife, he had started claiming he could see the devil.
和一支大麻烟斗。他还拥有一个从犹他州公路巡警那里偷来的雷达装置，价值4000美元。罗杰被控严重攻击、持有毒品和收受赃物。他表示不抗辩，指控被减轻，导致他被判缓刑。第二年，罗杰帮助一个朋友从五金店偷走了几十件工具。在遇到帕梅拉之前，罗杰也结过三次婚。1999年，罗杰和当时的妻子互相寻求保护令。据罗杰的妻子说，他开始声称他能看到魔鬼。
She also said that he abused cannabis and alcohol frequently and was physically violent, throwing her against a wall and slapping her. Roger said in his own protective order application that she was lying about these assaults. The orders were granted. but Roger was later convicted of violating it when he made harassing phone calls to his wife. A judge ordered Roger to attend anger management classes and the couple ultimately divorced. Roger's father Kay had been there during his son's struggles. He would bail him out when he needed it and helped Roger stop using drugs.
她还说他经常滥用大麻和酒精，并且有身体暴力，把她扔向墙壁并扇她耳光。罗杰在自己的保护令申请中说，她在这些袭击事件上撒谎。保护令被批准了，但罗杰后来因在给妻子打骚扰电话时违反了保护令而被定罪。法官命令罗杰参加愤怒管理课程，这对夫妇最终离婚了。罗杰的父亲凯在他儿子的挣扎期间一直都在。他会在他需要时保释他，并帮助罗杰停止使用毒品。
The pair bonded over their love of firearms and would trade guns together. Roger said that he and his dad had been best friends. Quote, As best friends as you can be with a grumpy old man. Shortly after Kay's murder, detectives learned that Roger had gone to a bank where Kay had kept a security box that contained more than $800,000 worth of gold and silver.
两人因对枪支的热爱而结缘，并会一起交易枪支。罗杰说他和他的父亲是最好的朋友。“引用：作为最好的朋友，你可以和一个脾气暴躁的老头成为朋友。”在凯被谋杀后不久，侦探们得知罗杰去了一家银行，凯在那里存放了一个保险箱，里面有价值超过80万美元的金银。
Roger had tried to access the security box, but wasn't allowed. The case investigators couldn't understand why Roger would do such a thing so soon after his father's murder, especially as he had siblings who were also entitled to Kay's estate. Roger's interest in his father's wealth looked like a clear motive to the police. Kay had put most of his money into a trust for his children to receive one day, and Roger was set to inherit a fortune in the event of his father's death. They froze and seized case assets. Investigators searched Roger and Pamela's home. Scattered throughout the house,
罗杰曾试图进入保险箱，但未被允许。案件调查人员无法理解为什么罗杰会在他父亲被谋杀后这么快就做这样的事，尤其是因为他还有其他有权继承凯遗产的兄弟姐妹。罗杰对他父亲财富的兴趣在警察看来是一个明确的动机。凯已经把他大部分的钱放入了一个信托基金，供他的孩子们有一天接收，而罗杰在父亲去世的情况下将继承一笔财富。他们冻结并扣押了案件资产。调查人员搜查了罗杰和帕梅拉的家。散落在房子各处，
detectives noticed a number of letters that turned out to be collection notices and unsent mortgage repayment forms. It seemed the couple owed thousands of dollars and were in financial trouble. This was consistent with Pamela's remark about being in debt during her police interview. detectives noticed some sawdust on the floor beneath a heating furnace with a wood panel. It looked as though someone had recently been meddling with the panel. They removed it and found a 12-gauge shotgun and an AK-47 stashed behind the furnace, along with several thousand rounds of ammunition. Roger Mortensen wasn't permitted to own guns due to his previous convictions.
侦探们注意到一些信件，结果发现是催款通知和未寄出的抵押贷款还款单。看起来这对夫妇欠了数千美元，陷入了经济困境。这与帕梅拉在警察审讯中提到负债的说法一致。侦探们注意到加热炉下方带木板的地板上有锯末。看起来好像有人最近动过那块板子。他们移开板子，在炉子后面发现了一把12号口径霰弹枪和一把AK-47，以及几千发弹药。罗杰·莫滕森由于之前的定罪而不被允许拥有枪支。
Believing these could be the firearms that had been stolen from Kay Mortensen's bunker, the detectives took them in for examination. In the garage, detectives found a safe with a 22-caliber revolver inside. There were also two round plastic containers in the garage that were filled with cannabis. Possessing cannabis for any purpose was illegal in Utah at the time, and Roger's criminal record meant he was committing a felony. Roger Mortensen's green jeep was also taken for processing. Detectives took Roger back to his father's house and asked him to take them through the events of the attack.
认为这些可能是从凯·莫滕森的掩体中被盗的枪支，侦探们将它们带走进行检查。在车库里，侦探们发现了一个保险箱，里面有一把22口径左轮手枪。车库里还有两个圆形的塑料容器，里面装满了大麻。在当时，出于任何目的持有大麻在犹他州都是非法的，而罗杰的犯罪记录意味着他犯了重罪。罗杰·莫滕森的绿色吉普车也被带走进行处理。侦探们把罗杰带回他父亲的房子，并要求他带他们重演袭击事件的经过。
They noted that during the walkthrough, Roger seemed very keen to go upstairs and check everything was still there. As the bathroom hadn't been cleaned and was still stained with Kay's blood, investigators found this odd. It didn't seem right that Kay's son would want to go near the spot where his father had been murdered. Roger repeatedly referred to the two perpetrators as gentlemen, which also seemed strange. The decision was made to give Roger and Pamela polygraph tests. Although the results from these tests wouldn't be permissible in a court of law, detectives wanted to measure the couple's responses to being asked directly if they had killed Kay. The polygraph examiner suspected Pamela was using countermeasures, like breathing differently, to beat the test.
他们注意到在重演过程中，罗杰似乎非常热衷于上楼检查一切是否还在。由于浴室没有清理过，仍然沾有凯的血迹，调查人员觉得这很奇怪。凯的儿子想要靠近他父亲被谋杀的地方似乎不太对劲。罗杰反复称那两名作案者为“绅士”，这也显得很奇怪。决定对罗杰和帕梅拉进行测谎测试。虽然这些测试的结果在法庭上不可采信，但侦探们想衡量这对夫妇在被直接问及是否杀害凯时的反应。测谎仪检查员怀疑帕梅拉使用了反制措施，比如改变呼吸方式，以通过测试。
Ultimately, her results were inconclusive. When Roger was tested, he became extremely animated and suddenly turned to the examiner saying, I know how my father was murdered. Then he got down on his hands and knees to pose in the position his father had been in, before making the motion of a knife across his throat. Not only was his re-enactment descriptive and disturbing, it matched the autopsy findings to a T. Roger's results indicated he had failed his polygraph test.
最终，她的结果是不确定的。当罗杰接受测试时，他变得极其活跃，突然转向检查员说：“我知道我父亲是怎么被谋杀的。”然后他跪在地上，摆出他父亲当时所处的姿势，然后做了一个刀划过喉咙的动作。他的重演不仅描述详细且令人不安，而且与尸检结果完全吻合。罗杰的结果表明他未能通过测谎测试。
Detectives believed he was being deceptive when he said he'd nothing to do with his father's murder. It was clear to them that Roger and Pamela had a financial motive and both had been behaving suspiciously from the beginning. Detectives weren't the only ones who suspected Roger and Pamela. Kay Mortensen's wife, Dala, had voiced her concerns. Kay's sister, Fern, didn't think Roger was personally capable of killing his father, but she did believe he might know people who would be willing to do it for him.
侦探们认为他在说自己与父亲的谋杀案无关时是在撒谎。对他们来说很清楚，罗杰和帕梅拉有经济动机，而且从一开始两人的行为就很可疑。并不是只有调查人员怀疑罗杰和帕梅拉。凯·莫滕森的妻子达拉表达了她的担忧。凯的妹妹费恩（Fern）不认为罗杰个人有能力杀害他的父亲，但她确实相信他可能认识愿意为他做这件事的人。
Two months after the murder, in January 2010, the Utah County State, Sheriff's Office went public and openly named the couple as persons of interest in the case. They also shared the audio from Pamela's 911 call with the media. A spokesperson from the Sheriff's Department explained that the couple had provided inconsistent information and also refused to help create a suspect sketch of the men they claimed were responsible. In the face of the media spotlight, Roger and Pamela continued to assert their innocence. and despite all the suspicion against them, there was no physical evidence tying them to the crime. The guns recovered from their home hadn't been the same one stolen from Kay's bunker.
谋杀案发生两个月后，即2010年1月，犹他县治安官办公室公开将这对夫妇列为该案的相关人员。他们还向媒体分享了帕梅拉拨打911的录音。治安官办公室的一位发言人解释说，这对夫妇提供的信息前后矛盾，并拒绝协助绘制他们声称应对此负责的男子的嫌疑人画像。面对媒体的聚光灯，罗杰和帕梅拉继续坚称自己无罪，尽管他们面临种种怀疑，但没有任何物证将他们与这起罪行联系起来。从他们家中搜出的枪支并非从凯的掩体中被盗的那把。
The case stalled for another six months. Then in July 2010, the Utah County prosecutor decided to convene a grand jury. This would allow them to share the evidence they did have with some witnesses, who would then decide whether there was enough to go to trial. The grand jury was kept secret from the public and the media. Sixteen jurors were presented with evidence from detectives, prosecutors, members of the Mortons and family, and some of Pamela's colleagues. Roger and Pamela weren't informed of the proceedings and no defence case was presented. On Thursday, July 29, 2010, the grand jury left to deliberate. It took them just over an hour to come to a conclusion.
案件又停滞了六个月。2010年7月，犹他县检察官决定召集大陪审团。这将允许他们与一些证人分享他们所掌握的证据，然后由证人决定是否有足够的证据进行审判。大陪审团对公众和媒体保密。十六名陪审员听取了侦探、检察官、莫滕森家族成员以及帕梅拉的一些同事提供的证据。罗杰和帕梅拉没有被告知诉讼程序，也没有进行辩护。2010年7月29日星期四，大陪审团退庭进行审议。他们仅用了一个多小时就得出了结论。
They voted in favour of the couple being indicted for Kay Mortensen's murder. One week later, on the evening of Thursday, August 5, Roger and Pamela Mortensen learnt of the indictment when police arrived at their home. Both were arrested and charged with murder and obstruction of justice. They were transferred to the Utah County Jail, where they would remain until it was time for their trial. Case File will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads.
他们投票赞成起诉这对夫妇谋杀凯·莫滕森。一周后，即8月5日星期四晚上，罗杰和帕梅拉·莫滕森在警察到达他们家时得知了起诉书。两人均被逮捕，并被控谋杀罪和妨碍司法公正罪。他们被转移到犹他县监狱，在那里一直关押到审判开始。Case File稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本期节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本期节目的广告。
By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. Rachel Bingham was growing increasingly concerned about reports she was seeing on the news. As a resident of Vernal, Utah, Rachel lived about a three hours drive from Kay Mortensen's residence, but the story of the professor's murder was still major local news. For months, Rachel, who was in her early 20s, had been keeping an awful secret, and now she was seeing the consequences of not telling anyone what she knew. Rachel had married when she was just 18 years old. Her husband, Martin Bond, had initially pursued a career in the military
通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供优质内容。瑞秋·宾厄姆对她在新闻中看到的报道越来越担心。作为犹他州弗纳尔的居民，瑞秋住的地方离凯·莫滕森的住所大约有三个小时的车程，但这位教授被谋杀的故事仍然是当地的主要新闻。几个月来，20出头的瑞秋一直保守着一个可怕的秘密，现在她看到了不告诉任何人她所知道的事情的后果。瑞秋在18岁时就结婚了。她的丈夫马丁·邦德最初追求的是军事生涯，
before he was discharged and enrolled at Utah State University. The young couple had a son together, but their marriage didn't work out. By early 2010, Rachel Bingham and Martin Bond were divorced. However, they remained good friends. In March 2010, not long after the day, their divorce was finalised, the now 23-year-old Bond confided something in his ex-wife. Martin Bond had known murder victim Kay Mortensen as his father was one of Kay's long-time friends. The two men had trained together in an emergency response program, developing a close friendship.
后来他退伍并进入犹他州立大学就读。这对年轻夫妇有一个儿子，但他们的婚姻并不顺利。到2010年初，瑞秋·宾厄姆和马丁·邦德已经离婚。然而，他们仍然是好朋友。2010年3月，在他们离婚手续办妥后不久，现年23岁的邦德向他的前妻吐露了一些事情。马丁·邦德认识谋杀受害者凯·莫滕森，因为他的父亲是凯的长期朋友之一。这两个人曾一起参加过应急响应培训项目，建立了深厚的友谊。
As a child, Bond had even visited Kay's home in Payson. Bond told Rachel that five months of... earlier on Monday, November 16, 2009, he and his childhood friend Benjamin Reddigg had driven to Kay's Payson residence. They went armed with zip tires and latex gloves and the intention to steal Kay's guns. Martin Bond needed money, and because he knew Kay Mortensen, he was aware that the elderly man had a valuable gun collection. Martin Bond knocked on Kay's front door as Benjamin Reddigg stood behind him. When Kay opened to the door, he immediately recognized Bond and invited both men inside. Once they were indoors, Redig and Bond pulled a 40-caliber handgun on Kay and demanded
小时候，邦德甚至去过凯在佩森的家。邦德告诉瑞秋，五个月前，即2009年11月16日星期一，他和儿时的朋友本杰明·雷迪格开车去了凯在佩森的住所。他们带着扎带和乳胶手套，意图偷走凯的枪支。马丁·邦德需要钱，而且因为他认识凯·莫滕森，他知道这位老人收藏了贵重的枪支。马丁·邦德敲了凯的前门，本杰明·雷迪格站在他身后。当凯开门时，他立刻认出了邦德，并邀请两人进屋。进入室内后，雷迪格和邦德用一把.40口径的手枪指着凯，要求
he restrain himself with the zip ties. Kay was reluctant, but didn't struggle and ultimately did as they asked. The pair then demanded Kay take them to where he kept his guns. Kaye. retrieved the key that led to his underground bunker and opened it up at gunpoint. Kay indicated where the firearms were located on the bunker's shelves, and the men then took Kay back inside the house. Familiar with the home's layout, Martin Bond forced Kay up the stairs and into a first-floor bathroom. He slid open the glass door on the bathtub before making Kay kneel over it. Bond zip tied Kay's feet together to prevent him from kicking out in self-defense. He told his ex-wife Rachel that while he stood watch over Kay,
他用扎带把自己绑起来。凯很不情愿，但没有挣扎，最终照他们说的做了。两人随后要求凯带他们去存放枪支的地方。凯取出了通往地下掩体的钥匙，并在枪口下打开了它。凯指出了掩体架子上存放枪支的位置，随后两人将凯带回了屋内。熟悉房屋布局的马丁·邦德强迫凯上楼，进入一楼的浴室。他滑开浴缸的玻璃门，让凯跪在上面。邦德用扎带把凯的脚绑在一起，以防他自卫踢人。他告诉前妻瑞秋，当他看守凯时，
Benjamin Reddick used a butcher knife taken from Kay's kitchen to slash Kay's throat. Reddick then stabbed Kay deep in the back of his neck before dropping the knife in the tub. Almost immediately after Kay was murdered, the doorbell rang. Benjamin Reddick hid behind the front door holding the handgun while Martin Bond opened the door. Roger and Pamela Mortensen were standing there with a pecan pie. After Bond to let them inside, Reddick emerged with the gun and ordered the couple into the living room.
本杰明·雷迪格用从凯的厨房拿来的屠刀割断了凯的喉咙。雷迪格随后将刀深深地刺入凯的后颈，然后把刀扔在浴缸里。凯被谋杀后几乎立刻，门铃响了。本杰明·雷迪格拿着手枪躲在门后，马丁·邦德打开了门。罗杰和帕梅拉·莫滕森拿着一个山核桃派站在那里。在邦德让他们进屋后，雷迪格拿着枪出现，命令这对夫妇进入客厅。
They took the couple hostage, restraining them with zip ties, as they'd done to Kaye. While Roger and Pamela were left alone, and terrified for up to 45 minutes, Reddick kept a watch over the couple. Meanwhile, Bond emptied the bunker of its 25 guns and ammunition, loading them into his blue hatchback that was parked in Kay's driveway. Martin Bond didn't tell his ex-wife Rachel why he and Redick had allowed the couple to live, but he did tell her how they'd come up with a story that Roger and Pamil should tell the police,
他们劫持了这对夫妇，像对待凯一样用扎带将他们捆绑起来。当罗杰和帕梅拉被单独留下，并惊恐万分长达45分钟时，雷迪格一直看守着他们。与此同时，邦德清空了掩体里的25支枪和弹药，把它们装进停在凯车道上的蓝色掀背车里。马丁·邦德没有告诉前妻瑞秋为什么他和雷迪格放过了这对夫妇，但他告诉了她他们是如何编造一个罗杰和帕梅拉应该告诉警察的故事，
that three black men were responsible for. the crime. If they didn't tell this story, Bond and Reddigg said they would kill them and their families. Bond told Rachel that he and Reddick had buried the guns somewhere in the desert near Vernal where they lived, but now he wanted to move them. He was nervous that Reddick might go to the police to confess and he didn't want any evidence of their crime to be found. Bond asked Rachel if she would help. Reluctantly, Rachel agreed. She hired a U-Haul on the morning of Wednesday, March 31, 2010, a little over four months after Kay's murder.
即三个黑人应对这起罪行负责。如果他们不讲这个故事，邦德和雷迪格说他们会杀了他们和他们的家人。邦德告诉瑞秋，他和雷迪格把枪埋在他们居住的弗纳尔附近的沙漠里的某个地方，但现在他想转移它们。他很紧张，担心雷迪格可能会去警察局自首，他不想让任何犯罪证据被发现。邦德问瑞秋是否愿意帮忙。瑞秋勉强同意了。她在2010年3月31日星期三早上租了一辆U-Haul，距离凯被谋杀已经过去了四个多月。
She then headed out to the desert with Bond and their young son. Bond retrieved Kay's guns and put them in the U-Haul, then they drove to a nearby park. It was a spacious park with wooded air. areas, numerous walking trails, and a giant cliff face 100 feet high. Rachel watched the couple's son and made a fire while Bond found a spot to re-burry the guns. He chose a secluded, wooded area. Rachel also took some snapshots of the cliff face that day, as well as a few of Bond standing next to the rented U-hall.
然后她和邦德以及他们的儿子一起前往沙漠。邦德取回了凯的枪，把它们放进U-Haul，然后他们开车去了附近的一个公园。那是一个宽敞的公园，有树木繁茂的区域、众多的步行道和一个100英尺高的巨大悬崖面。瑞秋照顾着这对夫妇的儿子并生了火，而邦德则找了一个地方重新埋藏这些枪支。他选择了一个偏僻的树木繁茂的区域。那天瑞秋还拍了一些悬崖面的快照，以及几张邦德站在租来的U-Haul旁边的照片。
For months, Rachel Bingham kept her ex-husband's secret. She saw some news stories about Kay's son and daughter-in-law being suspected of the crime, though nothing about them being arrested. Rachel tried blocking out the terrible things Bond had told her, but by late 2010, she couldn't keep what she knew to herself anymore. She confided in a friend, who in turn told her that Roger and Pamela Mortensen had since been charged with the crime. Rachel checked the news and saw that this was true.
几个月来，瑞秋·宾厄姆一直保守着前夫的秘密。她看到了一些关于凯的儿子和儿媳被怀疑犯罪的新闻报道，尽管没有关于他们被捕的消息。瑞秋试图屏蔽邦德告诉她的那些可怕的事情，但到了2010年底，她再也无法隐瞒自己所知道的一切了。她向一位朋友吐露了心声，而这位朋友反过来告诉她，罗杰和帕梅拉·莫滕森此后已被控犯罪。瑞秋查看了新闻，发现这是真的。
Horrified at the thought that two innocent people might serve life sentences for a murder her ex-husband had committed, Rachel decided to tell the truth. On Sunday December 5, 2010, four months since Roger and Pamela Mortensen had been sent to county jail, Rachel Bingham called the police. During an in-person interview that was recorded, Rachel, told detectives everything that Martin Bond had told her. She cried as she said how the prospect of the Mortensen's going to prison had prompted her to come forward. Rachel's story matched numerous details from the Mortensen's statements that had not been public and seemed to verify
想到两个无辜的人可能因为她前夫犯下的谋杀案而服无期徒刑，瑞秋感到恐惧，她决定说出真相。2010年12月5日星期日，距离罗杰和帕梅拉·莫滕森被送进县监狱已经过去了四个月，瑞秋·宾厄姆报了警。在一次录音的当面采访中，瑞秋告诉侦探马丁·邦德告诉她的一切。她哭着说，莫滕森夫妇入狱的前景促使她站了出来。瑞秋的故事与莫滕森夫妇陈述中许多未公开的细节相吻合，似乎证实了
their claims. Martin Bond and Benjamin Reddick were almost exactly as Roger and Pamela had described. They were white and in their early 20s with short dark hair and some facial hair. Both were of average height at 5'10 and weighed 165 pounds. Rachel also told the police that Bond hadn't buried all of Kay's guns. She had seen some of them still lying around his house. Investigators obtained a warrant to search Martin Bond's home. Bond told them he had nothing to do with the crime but couldn't stop them from executing the search warrant. While going through his home and a nearby shed, detectives found between five to seven guns that matched one stolen from Kay Mortensen.
他们的说法。马丁·邦德和本杰明·雷迪格与罗杰和帕梅拉描述的几乎完全一样。他们是白人，20出头，留着短黑发和一些胡须。两人身高都在5英尺10英寸左右，体重165磅。瑞秋还告诉警察，邦德并没有埋掉凯所有的枪。她看到其中一些仍然散落在他的房子里。调查人员获得了搜查马丁·邦德家的搜查令。邦德告诉他们他与这起罪行无关，但无法阻止他们执行搜查令。在搜查他的家和附近的一个棚屋时，侦探们发现了五到七支与从凯·莫滕森那里被盗的枪支相匹配的枪。
Most of them had the serial numbers scratched off, with the exception of one rifle. When investigators checked at serial number, they confirmed that the rifle had belonged to Kay Mortensen. Presented with this evidence, Martin Bond changed his story. He admitted that he had been involved and told the detectives the same story he had told Rachel. He then took them to the location where he'd buried the remaining guns. It was a wooded area about 10 feet from a parking lot within the large park Rachel Bingham had described. Detectives recovered more firearms from this buried weapons cache. Bond was adamant that he hadn't been the one to actually kill Kay.
其中大多数的序列号都被磨掉了，只有一支步枪除外。当调查人员检查该序列号时，他们证实这支步枪属于凯·莫滕森。面对这些证据，马丁·邦德改变了说法。他承认自己参与其中，并告诉侦探他告诉瑞秋的同一个故事。然后他带他们去了他埋藏剩余枪支的地点。那是一个树木繁茂的区域，距离瑞秋·宾厄姆描述的大公园里的停车场约10英尺。侦探们从这个埋藏的武器库中找回了更多的枪支。邦德坚称他并不是真正杀死凯的人。
He had stood over Kay with a gun while Benjamin Reddick repeatedly slashed his throat and stabbed him. It appeared that Kay had deliberately taken his attackers to the bunker because that was where his least expensive weapons were kept. He hadn't told them about the more valuable ones he kept upstairs in a safe. Bond and Reddick had seemingly taken Kay at face value, not thinking to search elsewhere in the property for other things to see. deal. When Benjamin Reddigg's home was searched, police found Roger Mortensen's driver's license in his possession. The couple had told police how the attackers had stolen Roger's license so they'd have access to his address. Two days after Rachel first went to the police, detectives arrested both men for aggravated murder, aggravated burglary and three counts of
他曾用枪指着凯，而本杰明·雷迪格反复割断了他的喉咙并刺伤了他。凯似乎故意把袭击者带到掩体，因为那是他存放最便宜武器的地方。他没有告诉他们他存放在楼上保险箱里的更贵重的武器。邦德和雷迪格似乎信以为真，没有想到在房产的其他地方寻找其他东西。当本杰明·雷迪格的家被搜查时，警察发现了罗杰·莫滕森的驾照。这对夫妇曾告诉警察袭击者是如何偷走罗杰的驾照，以便他们能获得他的地址。在瑞秋第一次向警方报案两天后，侦探们逮捕了这两名男子，罪名是加重谋杀、加重入室盗窃和三项
aggravated kidnapping. They were booked into the Utah County J. It was the same place where Roger and Pamela Mortensen had spent the past four months awaiting their trial. When Roger's attorney informed him of the new development in the case, Roger began crying. The day after Bond and Reddick were arrested, prosecutors moved to drop all charges against Roger and Pamela. The couple appeared happy and smiling as the indictment was officially dismissed in court. They declined to speak to the media, but Roger's attorney spoke on his behalf, stating, He and I are both just elated and ecstatic about this new development. I would suspect that a few things in life are as liberating as being proven innocent
加重绑架罪。他们被关进了犹他县监狱。这正是罗杰和帕梅拉·莫滕森过去四个月等待审判的地方。当罗杰的律师通知他案件的新进展时，罗杰开始哭泣。在邦德和雷迪格被捕后的第二天，检察官撤销了对罗杰和帕梅拉的所有指控。当起诉书在法庭上正式撤销时，这对夫妇显得很高兴，面带微笑。他们拒绝向媒体发表评论，但罗杰的律师代表他发言，称：“他和我都对这一新进展感到欣喜若狂。我怀疑生活中很少有事情能像被证明无罪那样令人解脱，
on something that everybody believes you did, especially something like murder. They've maintained the story the entire time, and it's all been true. Pamela Mortensen's lawyer said, I think there is some relief from Pam. I think that she always felt that the truth would come out. Every day that she sat in jail is a day of her life that was wasted and that she can never get back. Members of the couple's family openly expressed their relief at the news.
尤其是像谋杀这样每个人都认为你做了的事情。他们一直坚持这个故事，而且这一切都是真的。”帕梅拉·莫滕森的律师说：“我认为帕姆感到了一些解脱。我认为她一直觉得真相会大白。她在监狱里坐的每一天都是她浪费的生命，她永远无法找回。”这对夫妇的家人公开表达了他们对这一消息的宽慰。
Kay's widow Dala told reporters that she was shocked by the development, but incredibly relieved to know. her stepson had nothing to do with his father's murder. When police had first floated the idea that they could be responsible, Dala couldn't believe it. But then the investigators played recordings of their interviews for her. The couple's unusual demeanors led to Dala starting to suspect that they might have been involved. The relief that Roger and Pamela's relatives felt wasn't enough to undo some of the damage that
凯的遗孀达拉告诉记者，她对这一进展感到震惊，但得知继子与他父亲的谋杀案无关，她感到无比宽慰。当警察最初提出他们可能是肇事者时，达拉无法相信。但后来调查人员为她播放了他们的采访录音。这对夫妇不同寻常的举止导致达拉开始怀疑他们可能参与其中。罗杰和帕梅拉的亲属感到的宽慰不足以弥补过去一年中造成的一些损害。
had been done over the past year. The fact that some of their friends and people within Rogers' family had believed they were guilty had created significant tension and tested relationships. When the couple were first charged, Pamela's family hired an attorney for her, but Roger's relatives were less enthusiastic about funding his defense. According to the television program Dateline, when a friend of the couple asked Roger's sister, Julie, if they could use money from Kay's multi-million dollar estate to retain a lawyer for Roger, she refused. Julie told Dateline, this was because the family's attorney had advised against giving Roger money. Roger had to use a public defender instead. Kay's sister Fern had previously
事实上，他们的一些朋友和罗杰家族内部的人认为他们有罪，这造成了巨大的紧张关系并考验了人际关系。当这对夫妇最初被指控时，帕梅拉的家人为她聘请了一名律师，但罗杰的亲属对资助他的辩护不太热心。据电视节目《Dateline》报道，当这对夫妇的一位朋友问罗杰的姐姐朱莉，他们是否可以使用凯数百万美元遗产中的钱为罗杰聘请律师时，她拒绝了。朱莉告诉《Dateline》，这是因为家族的律师建议不要给罗杰钱。罗杰不得不使用公设辩护人。凯的姐姐弗恩此前
believed it might have been possible that Roger hired people to kill her brother. Although she was happy to be proven wrong, she was left with regret for not believing her nephew, and the experience changed her outlook on life. Family members and investigators alike had partly been suspicious of Roger and Pamela because some of their behaviour immediately following the attack was seen as odd. When Pamela called 911 after escaping from her zip ties, she came across as vague and unwilling to help the operator by providing information. This was because she wasn't sure if she should tell the truth of what happened, or the fake story that the attackers had ordered them to tell.
认为罗杰雇人杀害她哥哥是有可能的。虽然她很高兴被证明是错的，但她对自己不相信侄子感到后悔，这段经历改变了她的人生观。家人和调查人员都曾部分怀疑罗杰和帕梅拉，因为他们在袭击发生后的一些行为被认为是奇怪的。当帕梅拉在挣脱扎带后拨打911时，她显得含糊其辞，不愿通过提供信息来帮助接线员。这是因为她不确定是应该说出发生的事情的真相，还是袭击者命令他们说的假故事。
Detectives had been suspicious of how calm Pamela seemed in the aftermath of the attack, but she said that was her natural personality. She wasn't the type to become visibly emotional. Pamela also believed she had likely been. been in shock at the time. During Roger's interviews with detectives, he had said and done some things that they thought were strange. This included asking them if they thought his and Pamela's statements sounded, quote, too rehearsed.
侦探们曾怀疑帕梅拉在袭击发生后表现得如此冷静，但她说那是她自然的个性。她不是那种会表现出明显情绪的人。帕梅拉还认为她当时可能处于休克状态。在罗杰接受侦探采访时，他说过并做过一些他们认为奇怪的事情。这包括问他们是否认为他和帕梅拉的陈述听起来“太像排练过的”。
But there was a reason for this. Years earlier, Roger had accidentally driven his ATV off a cliff. He'd suffered a serious brain injury and almost died. Although he recovered, the injury caused significant trauma to his frontal lobe, and Roger was no longer able to work. He relied on disability payments instead. After the accident, elements of Roger's personality changed. He struggled with his short-term memory and stress caused him to become forgetful. He could also be impulsive or act as though he had no emotion or filter.
但这是有原因的。几年前，罗杰不小心把他的全地形车开下了悬崖。他遭受了严重的脑损伤，差点死亡。虽然他康复了，但伤势对他的额叶造成了严重的创伤，罗杰再也无法工作。他只能依靠残疾补助金生活。事故发生后，罗杰性格的某些方面发生了变化。他难以处理短期记忆，压力导致他变得健忘。他可能还会冲动，或者表现得好像没有情感或过滤机制。
These are common consequences of a frontal lobe injury. The grand jury that had voted to indict Roger and Pamela had not been told about Roger's injury. Investigators had told the grand jury that the couple hadn't provided clear and consistent descriptions of the men who attacked them. But a review of their statements proved this was false. The couple's level of debt had also been exaggerated. detectives had given evidence that they found several stacks of collection notices around their home, which were about eight or nine inches high. In fact, the couple only had three or four collection notices at the time, amounting to between
这些是额叶损伤的常见后果。投票起诉罗杰和帕梅拉的大陪审团并没有被告知罗杰的伤情。调查人员曾告诉大陪审团，这对夫妇没有提供关于袭击他们的人的清晰且一致的描述。但对他们陈述的审查证明这是错误的。这对夫妇的债务水平也被夸大了。侦探们提供的证据显示，他们在家里发现了好几叠催款通知，大约有八九英寸高。事实上，这对夫妇当时只有三四份催款通知，总额在
$3,000 and $8,000. These included medical and dental bills. The couple hadn't been behind on their mortgage payments. The reason there were unsent mortgage repriments, the reason there were unsent mortgage reprimand, payment forms lying around their house was because they had recently switched to making payments online. Investigators had told Roger and Pamela that their descriptions of the attack sounded too similar and rehearsed. Yet, they also pointed to discrepancies in their stories as indicators of guilt. These discrepancies were minor, such as the couple describing the man's
3000美元到8000美元之间。这些包括医疗和牙科账单。这对夫妇并没有拖欠抵押贷款。家里之所以有未寄出的抵押贷款还款表格，是因为他们最近改成了在线支付。调查人员曾告诉罗杰和帕梅拉，他们对袭击的描述听起来太相似且像排练过的。然而，他们也指出他们故事中的差异是内疚的指标。这些差异很小，例如这对夫妇描述男子的
gloves as different colours. Mistakes in recollecting details such as this are, aren't uncommon after suffering a traumatic experience. The couple were accused of having refused to help create a sketch of the suspects. In fact, they had been at the Sheriff's Department with their attorney to provide fingerprints and DNA samples when investigators unexpectedly brought out a sketch artist. Because their attorney had another appointment in court, they were unable to stay and work with the sketch artist at that time. The attorney asked if they could complete the sketch another time, but the police never followed up.
手套颜色不同。在遭受创伤性经历后，对细节的回忆出现错误并不罕见。这对夫妇被指控拒绝协助绘制嫌疑人的画像。事实上，他们当时正和律师在治安官办公室提供指纹和DNA样本，调查人员突然带出了一位画像师。因为他们的律师在法庭上还有另一个预约，他们当时无法留下来与画像师合作。律师问他们是否可以在其他时间完成画像，但警察从未跟进。
It also emerged that early in the investigation, detectives had been contacted by a woman who said she had witnessed the murder in a dream. The woman had been using methamphetamine at the time and had a very vivid dream in which she saw her boyfriend murder Kay Mortensen in his bathroom. A second woman was present on a nearby staircase and was a very bigelisk and was a very vivid dream. was crying during the murder. She was accompanied by a man. Detectives wondered if the man and woman watching on during the murder could have been Roger and Pamela. They showed the woman a photo lineup of suspects, with Roger's picture included.
调查中还出现了一个情况，调查初期，侦探们接到了一名女子的电话，她说她在梦中目睹了谋杀案。该女子当时正在使用甲基苯丙胺，并做了一个非常生动的梦，梦见她的男友在浴室里谋杀了凯·莫滕森。第二个女人出现在附近的楼梯上，正在哭泣。她由一个男人陪同。侦探们想知道在谋杀过程中观看的男人和女人是否可能是罗杰和帕梅拉。他们向该女子展示了一组嫌疑人照片，其中包括罗杰的照片。
They asked her to identify the killer, and she pointed directly at Roger. Despite the fact that this woman was reporting a dream she'd had while under the influence, of recreational drugs, detectives had treated this as a serious tip-off. It had further bolstered their early suspicions that Roger and Pamela Mortensen were somehow involved. After Martin Bond and Benjamin Reddick were charged with Kay's murder, Redig's attorney soon helped him negotiate a plea agreement with prosecutors. The agreement would see Redig plead guilty to aggravated murder and just one count of aggravated kidnapping. In exchange, the prosecutors would drop the other charges and wouldn't seek the death penalty in his case. They would even recommend the possibility of parole one day when it came to sentencing.
他们让她指认凶手，她直接指向了罗杰。尽管该女子报告的是她在受娱乐性药物影响时做的梦，但侦探们还是将其视为一条严肃的线索。这进一步加强了他们早先对罗杰和帕梅拉·莫滕森以某种方式参与其中的怀疑。在马丁·邦德和本杰明·雷迪格被控谋杀凯之后，雷迪格的律师很快帮助他与检察官协商了一项认罪协议。该协议将使雷迪格承认加重谋杀罪和一项加重绑架罪。作为交换，检察官将撤销其他指控，并且不会在他的案件中寻求死刑。他们甚至会在量刑时建议未来假释的可能性。
Part of Reddigg's play agreement required him to make a full and honest confession and testify against Bond when it came time for his trial. The plan to rob Kay Mortensen hadn't been a long time in the making. Redig said that he'd first heard of Bond's idea when Bond called him on the day of the crime. Reddigg had gone over to Bond's home and things escalated from there. Redig's version of events differed somewhat from Bond's. While Bond said his friend was responsible for killing Kay, Redig said it was the other way around.
雷迪格认罪协议的一部分要求他做出全面且诚实的供述，并在审判时出庭指证邦德。抢劫凯·莫滕森的计划并非蓄谋已久。雷迪格说，他是在案发当天邦德打电话给他时才第一次听说邦德的想法。雷迪格去了邦德家，事情从那里开始升级。雷迪格对事件的描述与邦德的有些不同。虽然邦德说他的朋友应对杀死凯负责，但雷迪格说情况恰恰相反。
After zip tying Kay's ankles in the bathroom, Bond had gone downstairs to the kitchen and returned with a butcher. a knife. Reddick had been the one holding the handgun the entire time. He'd been standing in the bathroom with the gun while Bond repeatedly sliced Kay's throat, then stabbed him. According to Reddick, Bond had also wanted to kill Roger and Pamela. After the couple were first restrained, Bond had gone back to the kitchen and found a second knife. But this time, Redig intervened, stepping between Bond and the couple and telling Bond not to kill them. As Martin Bond was pleading not guilty and going to trial,
在浴室里用扎带绑住凯的脚踝后，邦德下楼去了厨房，拿了一把屠刀回来。雷迪格一直拿着手枪。当邦德反复割断凯的喉咙，然后刺伤他时，他一直拿着枪站在浴室里。据雷迪格说，邦德还想杀死罗杰和帕梅拉。在这对夫妇最初被控制后，邦德回到厨房找了第二把刀。但这一次，雷迪格进行了干预，挡在邦德和这对夫妇之间，告诉邦德不要杀他们。由于马丁·邦德拒不认罪并准备接受审判，
Redig's version of events would be heard in court when he testified against his long-time friend. Benjamin Reddick officially pleaded guilty in June 2011. He was sentenced to 25 years to life in prison and ordered to pay two fines of $10,000 each. The judge also ordered Reddick to pay restitution amounting to $10,500. In a brief statement to the court, Reddick apologized multiple times for his role in Kay's murder. Martin Bond's trial began years later in January 2013. His ex-wife, Rachel Bingham, was a star witness and cried as she testified from the witness box. Benjamin Reddick was set to be another key witness.
雷迪格对事件的描述将在他出庭指证这位老朋友时被听到。本杰明·雷迪格于2011年6月正式认罪。他被判处25年至终身监禁，并被勒令支付两笔各10,000美元的罚款。法官还命令雷迪格支付10,500美元的赔偿金。在给法庭的一份简短声明中，雷迪格多次为他在凯谋杀案中的角色道歉。马丁·邦德的审判于多年后的2013年1月开始。他的前妻瑞秋·宾厄姆是明星证人，她在证人席上作证时哭了。本杰明·雷迪格被设定为另一位关键证人。
He was brought into the courtroom wearing a white prison jumpsuit. Reddick was asked about his childhood and his friendship with Martin Bond. He answered these questions openly. Then he was asked about the events of Monday, November 16, 2009. Reddick said he'd been at the restaurant where he worked when he received a call from Bond asking him to come over. When the prosecutor asked what happened next, Reddick paused, then replied. I know it was in the agreement to, and everyone expects me to, but I would feel more comfortable stopping right now. The prosecutor tried asking more questions, but Redig refused to answer them,
他穿着白色囚服被带进法庭。雷迪格被问及他的童年以及他与马丁·邦德的友谊。他公开回答了这些问题。然后他被问及2009年11月16日星期一发生的事件。雷迪格说，当他接到邦德要求他过去的电话时，他正在工作的餐厅。当检察官问接下来发生了什么时，雷迪格停顿了一下，然后回答说：“我知道协议里有，每个人也都期待我这么做，但我现在更愿意停止。”检察官试图问更多问题，但雷迪格拒绝回答，
quietly telling the court he was refusing to testify. The prosecution and Kay Mortensen's family were deeply disappointed by Reddick's refusal, especially as it had been negotiated as part of his plea deal. Bond's defence were claiming the entire attack had been Redig's idea. They said Bond had reluctantly agreed to rob Kay's property, but only if Kay wasn't home. Bond considered Kay a close friend and didn't want to harm him. If the pair arrived at Kay's residence and found he was there,
平静地告诉法庭他拒绝作证。检方和凯·莫滕森的家人对雷迪格的拒绝深感失望，尤其是因为这已经作为他认罪协议的一部分进行了协商。邦德的辩护律师声称整个袭击都是雷迪格的主意。他们说邦德只是勉强同意抢劫凯的房产，但前提是凯不在家。邦德认为凯是一个亲密的朋友，不想伤害他。如果两人到达凯的住所发现他在家，
Bond insisted that they would just say hello and leave. He said that somehow the entire thing had just gotten out of hand. According to Bond and his attorney, Redig was also solely responsible for Kay's murder. Redig going back on his deal with prosecutors wouldn't impact his conviction, but it would be passed along to the parole board to review when he is able to apply for parole. Since they were arrested, Bond and Reddick had each accused the other of killing Kay. The prosecution had been relying on Reddick to prove their case against Bond, but they did have another witness willing to testify that Bond was the killer.
邦德坚持说他们只会打个招呼就离开。他说，不知何故，整件事失控了。据邦德和他的律师称，雷迪格也应对凯的谋杀负全部责任。雷迪格违背与检察官的协议不会影响他的定罪，但当他能够申请假释时，这将被传达给假释委员会进行审查。自从被捕以来，邦德和雷迪格互相指责对方杀害了凯。检方一直依靠雷迪格来证明他们对邦德的指控，但他们还有另一位愿意作证邦德是凶手的证人。
In 2011, Martin Bond had been caught passing notes with another inmate at the Utah County Jail. The other inmate was a 21-year-old awaiting trial for robbing a crime. credit union. The two would communicate by typing handwritten notes to a shoestring and tossing it between their cells. One night, the 21-year-old inmate asked Bond why he was placing all the blame for Kay's murder on his childhood friend. In response, Bond wrote, Well, Ben made the situation. When Kay and I tried to talk to him, he freaked out more and a bunch of other shit happened. It came to the point where Ben was going to kill him, but he made me instead.
2011年，马丁·邦德在犹他县监狱被抓到与另一名囚犯传递纸条。另一名囚犯是一名21岁、因抢劫信用社而等待审判的人。两人通过将手写纸条系在鞋带上并在牢房之间投掷来进行交流。一天晚上，这名21岁的囚犯问邦德为什么把凯谋杀案的所有责任都推给他的儿时朋友。作为回应，邦德写道：“好吧，是本造成了这种情况。当凯和我试图和他谈话时，他更加惊慌失措，然后发生了一堆其他破事。到了本要杀他的地步，但他让我来做。”
It was that, or he said he'll shoot me so that no one could say anything. That's why Kay's throat was cut. Ben wouldn't give me the gun. I thought he was suffering, so that's why I stabbed him. The younger inmate came forward with the notes in exchange for a better plea deal in his own case. A handwriting expert from the Salt Lake County Police Department said that the note was written in neat cursive and was a match to Bond's handwriting. A former friend of Martin Bond said that over the years, Bond had occasionally discussed how he would murder a person if he ever had to. He would talk about slicing throats, the friend said. That's how he would do it. Slicing throats.
“要么是那样，要么他说他会开枪打死我，这样就没人能说什么了。这就是为什么凯的喉咙被割开了。本不肯把枪给我。我以为他在受苦，所以这就是我刺伤他的原因。”这名年轻的囚犯带着这些纸条站了出来，以换取他自己案件中更好的认罪协议。盐湖县警察局的一位笔迹专家说，纸条是用整洁的草书写的，与邦德的笔迹相符。马丁·邦德的一位前朋友说，多年来，邦德偶尔会讨论如果他不得不杀人，他会怎么做。“他会谈论割喉，”这位朋友说，“那就是他会做的方式。割喉。”
The Utah County Attorney also argued that Bond was the one with a motive to kill Kay, not Reddick. Kay knew who Bond was, but had never seen Reddick before. It made sense that Bond would want to cover his tracks by murdering a victim who could identify him. Roger and Pamela Mortensen testified at length about their ordeal at the hands of Bond and Reddick. Now that they knew the names of their attackers, they could provide more information about how each man had behaved. Pamela said it was Bond who did most of the talking and seemed to be in charge. Reddick had been quieter and was the one who had told the couple
犹他县检察官还辩称，邦德才是那个有动机杀害凯的人，而不是雷迪格。凯认识邦德是谁，但以前从未见过雷迪格。邦德想要通过谋杀一个能认出他的受害者来掩盖自己的踪迹，这是说得通的。罗杰和帕梅拉·莫滕森详细作证了他们在邦德和雷迪格手中的遭遇。现在他们知道了袭击者的名字，他们可以提供更多关于每个人行为方式的信息。帕梅拉说，大部分谈话都是邦德在进行，他似乎是负责人。雷迪格比较安静，是那个告诉这对夫妇
K was restrained upstairs. Pamela told the court how terrified she had been, quote, It was a very scary situation. I didn't know if I was going to make it out of that house that night. Three days after the trial began, the jury left to deliberate. It took them five hours to find Martin Bond guilty of aggravated murder, burglary and robbery, and three counts of aggravated kidnapping. He was sentenced to life in prison without the possibility of parole. Roger and Pamela spoke openly about the devastating consequences the crime had on them. They had lost a loved one in terrible circumstances and were also victims of kidnapping. Being taken hostage and believing they would be murdered had been a traumatic experience.
凯在楼上被绑住的人。帕梅拉告诉法庭她当时有多害怕，“那是一个非常可怕的情况。我不知道那天晚上我是否能活着离开那所房子。”审判开始三天后，陪审团退庭进行审议。他们用了五个小时认定马丁·邦德犯有加重谋杀、入室盗窃和抢劫罪，以及三项加重绑架罪。他被判处终身监禁，不得假释。罗杰和帕梅拉公开谈论了这起罪行对他们造成的毁灭性后果。他们在可怕的情况下失去了一位亲人，也是绑架案的受害者。被劫持为人质并认为自己会被谋杀是一次创伤性的经历。
Then they were arrested and charged with the very crime they were victims of, losing months of their lives in the process. Addressing Martin Bond directly during his sentencing, Roger stated, Because of your actions, my wife and I were blamed for a crime we did not commit. admit. We spent four and a half months in jail. Our relationships with family and friends were destroyed. My wife lost her job. Our vehicles were repossessed. Our reputations were ruined in our church and in our community, while you watched it happen and bragged about it. Roger and Pamela filed a civil lawsuit against those responsible for their arrest,
然后他们被逮捕并被指控犯有他们作为受害者的罪行，在此过程中失去了几个月的生命。在量刑时直接对马丁·邦德讲话，罗杰说：“因为你的行为，我和我的妻子被指控犯下了一起我们没有犯下的罪行。我们在监狱里待了四个半月。我们与家人和朋友的关系被摧毁了。我的妻子失去了工作。我们的车辆被收回了。我们的名誉在我们的教会和社区中被毁了，而你却看着这一切发生并以此吹嘘。”罗杰和帕梅拉对那些应对他们被捕负责的人提起了民事诉讼，
arguing that the prosecutors and detectives had lied to the grand jury. But a few months after their suit was filed, the US Supreme Court ruled that grand jury prosecutors and witnesses were immune from civil litigation. Consequently, the couple's lawsuit was dismissed. They had no further recourse for restitution or compensation. Deputy Utah County Attorney Tim Taylor has said that although investigators made a mistake in arresting the couple, it was their arrests that. that led to the truth coming out. Taylor told the Salt Lake Tribune that he and other members of the prosecution team, quote, feel bad about Pamela and Roger Mortensen's arrests, but in the long run, things turned out okay. In the words of Kay Mortensen's sister Fern, his murder and the events that followed, permanently damaged Kay's loved ones. In court, she stated, Our
辩称检察官和侦探对大陪审团撒了谎。但在诉讼提起几个月后，美国最高法院裁定大陪审团检察官和证人免受民事诉讼。因此，这对夫妇的诉讼被驳回。他们没有进一步的追偿或赔偿途径。犹他县副检察官蒂姆·泰勒表示，虽然调查人员在逮捕这对夫妇时犯了错误，但正是他们的逮捕导致了真相大白。泰勒告诉《盐湖城论坛报》，他和检方团队的其他成员，“对帕梅拉和罗杰·莫滕森的被捕感到难过，但从长远来看，事情结果还不错。”用凯·莫滕森的姐姐弗恩的话说，他的谋杀案和随后的事件永久地伤害了凯的亲人。在法庭上，她陈述道：“我们的
family was left with a gaping hole. Irreparable damage was done and will never be repaired. At the time of Kay's murder, he was just getting started on enjoying his retirement. He had only recently married his wife Dala, whom he was deeply devoted to. Dala described their relationship as being like that of teenagers newly in love. It had been a while since either of them had been in a loving relationship, and they were thrilled to have found each other. Kay and Dala were wealthy and happy and excited to spend the rest of their lives having fun together. The pair had completed a church mission, gone on a cruise to Hawaii, enrolled in dance classes, and had lots of other plans for their golden years.
家庭留下了一个巨大的缺口。造成了无法弥补的损害，永远无法修复。”在凯被谋杀时，他才刚刚开始享受退休生活。他不久前才与他深爱的妻子达拉结婚。达拉形容他们的关系就像刚坠入爱河的青少年。他们俩已经很久没有处于一段充满爱的关系中了，他们很高兴找到了彼此。凯和达拉富有、快乐，并期待着余生在一起享受乐趣。这对夫妇完成了教会使命，去夏威夷游轮旅行，报名参加了舞蹈班，并为他们的黄金岁月做了许多其他计划。
All of that abruptly ended when Martin Bond and Benjamin Reddick decided to rob Kay. In Dala's words, she had been left all alone by their actions, and the lives of Kay's son and a daughter-in-law were shattered, all for a few guns. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当马丁·邦德和本杰明·雷迪格决定抢劫凯时，这一切戛然而止。用达拉的话说，她因他们的行为而孤身一人，凯的儿子和儿媳的生活也被粉碎了，这一切仅仅是为了几把枪。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。